[Music]
you are notoriously generous when it
comes to tipping you are famous among
not just athletes but celebrities in
general for being a great tipper
is this true how good are you at tipping
I think it's important when you're
successful you know that the waiters or
waitresses the blackjack dealers I do I
think it's important you know they work
extremely hard they don't get a great
salary I think and the more successful
you are I think the more you should tip
I truly believe that do you ever do you
ever chipped somebody and you then later
on you had regrets like I think that was
too much I went overboard I mean what's
that what's a crazy tip for you I've
never went overboard yeah I mean I've to
$25,000 before you chip $25,000 do you
mind if I bring your car around when
it's time for you to go yeah I want
about $700,000 I was out of blackjack I
was playing you won $700,000 yeah oh my
god dr. tip I probably should have
tipped more to be on the floor yeah I
think in that context you're kind of a
cheap suit yeah yeah it's a bad fit
I could see that dealer being like what
the hell yeah you know but I thought I
was pretty generous cuz you know when
you lose money they don't give me any
back right to the point
okay you're pretty good at telling the
the absolute truth who are the cheapest
guys that you've hung out with that we
would know well there's nobody cheaper
than Scottie Pippen and Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan pretty Michael Jordan is
is cheap oh yeah he's food like how
cheap we're talking super cheap here
like you know what like you know I
always give homeless people money yeah
and he'll always slap my hand he says if
you big and ask you for spare change
they can say welcome to McDonald's can I
help you please Wow seriously oh yeah
Kotori says that
I like it more than Michael Jordan's a
slapper yeah
that's what is it okay so those guys are
cheap taco pretty cheap Tiger Woods oh
yeah yeah well you've made two of the
richest guys in of all time I'm Tiger
Woods chief I think that's what a rich
they don't tell it's a very fine alive
that's their secret right so secretive
being arrested on two very uh very nice
have you talked to tiger battered I have
not you first of all you good - you're
not the easygoing guy either when it
come to tipping you say it that didn't
yeah well that's an absolute lie I make
it rain Porter's
what's raining isn't it doesn't matter
what denomination